this is a production of cornell
university
great thanks dawn for the introduction
and yeah i can't express how
happy i am to be back um be it virtually
it's an honor to come back and uh have a
chance to share
what i've been up to in the four years
since leaving
cornell uh i still think back often
times particularly in the autumn
about how gorgeous the campus and all of
the area is and i hope that you can all
get back on campus
uh soon because it is something that i
missed dearly
so i'm going to take you on a bit of a
walk across north america
in 350 meters and we'll see
what the 350 meters references shortly
um
but first i wanted to acknowledge that
you're seeing a very
small portion of what ubc botanical
garden
has to offer and if any of you ever make
it out to this part
of my beautiful country i'd encourage
you to visit the garden
i'm one of four curators here this is
the rest of our curatorial team
um laura caddy on the left curates our
alpine garden
uh ryo tsujiyama in
the middle there is the curator for our
japanese
garden and there's me on the right in
the red
behind me is andy hill and he curates
our asian garden
quite a significant collection here and
in the back
uh with the beard is douglas justice and
he's the associate director of
horticulture and curation
so collectively this team uh stewards
much more
than you will have a chance to see today
and i wanted to acknowledge
the work that they do collectively this
team
um curates and stewards close to 8 000
accessions
in our garden representing uh 5
270 different taxa from 189 plant
families
uh represented by over a thousand genera
so you'll see a small uh snippet of our
garden
and if you find yourself in this part of
the world please come and see us
and reach out to me i'd be happy to uh
to give you a tour of
the rest of the garden as well i also
wanted to acknowledge before starting
that university of british columbia
is on the land of the musqueam people
this is our local
indigenous band here and the university
campus in point grey where i'm located
is on the traditional ancestral and
unseated territory of the musqueam
people
so i wanted to acknowledge that before
moving forward
to give you a sense of where i am in our
vast continent for those that aren't
familiar with the wild wild west uh
this is north america obviously and the
red circle on the upper left
is the location of southern british
columbia
it's quite a remarkable part of the
continent if you haven't had a chance to
visit
please do we zoom in a little bit more
this is
the greater vancouver area the fraser
river is a large
very important river here river system
for the local ecology and the local
people
and the red circle that you're seeing
this time
is vancouver's point grey campus this is
the site for our botanic garden
we have a wonderful coastal situation
looking out onto the salish sea
if we zoom in a little bit further this
is point grey campus itself
and if you look in the lower left you'll
see another shape sort of drawn
out this long sort of peninsular space
and uh this sort of awkward space that
wraps around a stadium here
this is the site of ubc botanical garden
currently our garden has celebrated our
103rd
anniversary and over that time we've
actually moved sites twice
we've been at this site since the 1970s
if we zoom in a little bit closer this
is the botanical garden site itself
vancouver has seen a tremendous amount
of growth over the last decades
and with that growth has come more
infrastructure
so what you see is our garden is
currently
divided into by a four-lane divided
highway this was not always the case
um so we have our southwest gardens
and our northeast gardens for today's
talk we're going to focus in
even further on the northeast gardens
and in particular
the space that's outlined here are the
north american gardens
here at ubc the north american gardens
are comprised of four
distinct garden areas representing the
biogeographical and floristic
communities of four
distinct regions the first is
our bc rainforest garden this is where
we will start our journey of 350 meters
the second being the pacific slope
garden
[Music]
then we'll move to the gary oak meadow
and woodland garden
and finally the carolinian forest garden
the title of the presentation references
the fact that you can
walk from the beginning of the
rainforest garden to the beginning of
the carolinian forest which is the walk
that we will do
in 350 meters and this is a really great
um
opportunity for people to come to our
garden and see the native flora
of this region but also of eastern north
america as well
so we're going to start with our
bc rainforest garden
i i showed you the region that we were
in a little bit earlier and
vancouver is fortunate to be situated in
one of north america's temperate
rainforest regions
um we receive annually over 50 inches of
rainfall
that happens here and we're extremely
moderated by our proximity to the
pacific ocean
our to give you a sense of just how
moderate our
our annual temperature in january which
is our coldest month
is 36 degrees fahrenheit so
still above freezing we do get snow here
but it never stays for more than a day
or two
and in the heat of summer in august or
sort of july which is our hottest month
we'll reach an average of 55 degrees so
also quite moderate we do have some heat
for sure but overall we're quite a
moderate climate and as a result we have
this lush
temperate rainforest environment that
we're situated in
our bc rainforest garden does not look
quite as lush as that first image
we are situated in an area that has been
heavily developed
and altered over time so while this
garden does
seek to represent the local bc
rainforest
plant communities authentically there
are some aspects of
our local rainforest that we just can't
replicate
given lower humidity due to development
and increased air movement and that sort
of thing
the garden itself i wanted to
acknowledge a couple of people in the
creation of it and so the bc
rainforest garden is actually dedicated
to the man in the lower right and his
name is john davidson
he was the first provincial botanist for
british columbia and was
later brought on by the university to
start
the botanical gardens themselves in 1819
and above him is a man named al rose and
al rose was a very
active employee at the botanic garden he
was the first curator for our native
garden
in the 70s and 80s and he was
by all accounts an exceptional field
botanist
and horticulturist he did a tremendous
amount of work
collecting plants from all over the
province
from our wet rainforest coast through to
our dry interior
up to our far far north and alpine
areas he made
something like a thousand collections a
year for a decade and a half
and to give you perspective a good
collecting year for me
i would probably get a 200 maybe
so he was an exceptional individual in
building these collections
um however when he retired in the 80s
funding and staffing structures
didn't allow for his replacement so al
rose built this garden that was
representative of flora from all over
the province really really rich
collection
and then it was abandoned by by and
large
for over a decade and during that time
this garden space
a number of those plants that were not
locally adapted
and couldn't survive without the
horticultural care had died
uh out sad story but there are some
still uh some beautiful
relics from his time and so this is what
that garden looks like
now um we've narrowed the scope from bc
native to
bc rainforest native to reflect the
plants that can
survive and are locally adapted
it looks very much like some of the
park spaces that happen in and around
vancouver
and in some ways that's challenging to
get people to understand that they are
in fact in a garden and not in a park
when they're in this space however the
trade-off is that we have some really
lovely moments that happen that are
fully natural expressing the local
ecology and so on the right we see an
old stump of a western red cedar
and our western hemlocks grow out of
these stumps
and you end up with these incredibly
beautiful moments in a garden that would
be
almost impossible to recreate
if this garden wasn't given that time on
its own
so the the balance here is that we have
some
some really great demonstrations of
local ecology
and a number of ubc's gardens visitors
are actually tourists we have a huge
tourist population
so i love this garden because people
come from all over the world
and within the garden itself can see
intact functioning local ecology
there are a number of uh of accessions
in here that are
remaining from al rose's time and i've
also been fortunate to build these
collections up
over the last few years and it's amazing
what can happen when you get back into a
garden space
and and provide that care it's a
wonderful
uh garden particularly in the early
spring when things are
leafing out and it's just this lush
light green
and importantly you know they're the
gardens themselves are not all about
plants we do a lot of work with people
as well
and uh i wanted to just highlight one
particular
relationship that i'm privileged to be
involved in
and it's relevance to my role as a
curator
so on the left is a white fawn lily a
plant called erythronium oregonum
and this plant in the picture here is
actually one of al rose's historic
collections
being in the garden for uh 35 plus years
and i've always admired it in the spring
it's beautiful spring ephemeral
um very very beautiful plant
and through some partnerships i've
learned that there's just so much more
to this plant
and so on the right you'll see a photo
of
tara moreau is on the left she is our
associate director of sustainability and
community programs
and in the middle is vanessa campbell
vanessa is
a language specialist with the musculum
indian band and then there's me on the
right and we've been working
to do a lot of co-created
programming and knowledge sharing
between the botanic garden and the
musqueam people
and through this dialogue
i learned that the musqueam the name
musqueam
for the indian ban translates to
people of the river grass and
the story is so powerful related
to the creation of the salmon streams
that sustain
the indigenous cultures here and
the story is that a double-headed
serpent carved these
these streams and in the wake of that
carving of those streams
the river grass grew along these rivers
however it's kind of been lost over time
what river grass is um
the written and oral histories
associated with a number of indigenous
cultures are only now just sort of being
pieced back together
and there's some talk uh through vanessa
she shared some wonderful
insights with me that the plant itself
there's one story that the grass
produced
a a white nodding flower in the early
spring and there's some
thought that it actually might be this
plant
and so as a curator my role is to
you know manage these collections and
all of the sudden
one of al rose's historic collections
takes on
even greater importance given its
relevance to
our our local our neighbors the musqueam
are literally
the garden's closest neighbors and whose
land we are on
so this has been one of the really
rewarding aspects of my job is working
with people as much as plants
i'm going to move on to the next garden
area
in our 350 meter journey
this is our pacific slope garden so
we're moving out of one of the oldest
garden areas
on site and certainly the oldest in the
north american collections to the newest
garden area
a little bit about you know what is the
pacific slope the pacific slope
uh basically denotes the western facing
slopes
of the coast range mountains and the
cascade ranges
including the klamath mountains and the
siskiyous
it's it's a an ecosystem that ranges
basically
from northern washington state
through oregon and down into northern
california
in this area if you've ever been it's
truly spectacular
and it's most well known for its
gigantic
conifers you see a picture on the right
this was a trip i was fortunate
to be on with some folks from the royal
botanical garden edinburgh when they
were doing some collecting here
and the smaller tree in the center is by
all accounts
a massive western hemlock but it's
completely dwarfed
by these enormous sitka spruce and this
is not an uncommon sight
along the pacific slope
it's important in particular for its
richness in conifer diversity so this is
a map that denotes
uh species richness in conifers
throughout the world
and what you'll see is you know we've
got some hot spots
in around japan southeast asia the
highest conifer diversity
is in new caledonia ubc botanical garden
doesn't have any collections under
glass we don't have greenhouses outside
of our propagation facilities
so we're not going to be growing those
plants but if you turn your eyes to
north america
what you see is that region that we saw
in the earlier slide
those western slopes have extremely high
conifer diversity
in a global context and this is a really
great opportunity for
conifer conservation a lot of these
plants
occur in very limited areas and if you
think about climate change and the
projections for that
well for the entirety of the world but
in particular that region
quite severe you know california's on
fire how many times do you hear that
uh a year um so we're
looking to turn our focus to conor for
conservation
and there are projections that in light
of climate change
our climate may actually be better
suited for some of these plants
in the long run and this is some of the
work that i do as a curator is planning
a garden not just for the next three
five ten years but hundreds of years and
so
we're focusing this garden in on the
conifers
however it's not all about conifers
we're also targeting the phage so the
oak family and these are a couple
accessions that are currently in there
that
i don't think people think oak as being
particularly gorgeous but there are some
examples um quercus callaghia the
california black oak on the left
it leafs out with these sort of velvety
pink leaves that
i think rival any of the magnolias in
terms of beauty
and nothing lithocarpus densiforus just
with these really cute little
um nuts starting to form and a nice
flush of velvety new growth
this garden is again as i say the
earliest so
last year received a very generous
donation from some of our
network of people that support the
garden and this is how project work
happens um you know so we've been
sitting on this idea for a number of
years
there's an injection of funds and we
start to move forward so this is
some of the early work that i did with
the landscape architect here
developing some concept plans and
refining the scope
and i'm happy to say that just last
month we started breaking ground and
this is
currently what this garden looks like so
you can see we've moved from a garden
that has
40 years of history in the rainforest
garden to one that is just
currently taking shape tremendously
excited about this garden
there's a lot of opportunity for
interpretation
to our our visitors about the impacts
of climate change on biodiversity in our
region
fortunately the photo i showed earlier
of
colleagues from the royal botanical
garden edinburgh on a collecting
expedition
fortunately we did participate in an
expedition
throughout this region a few years ago
so these young plants
in our nursery are ready to go out
into the garden and as you can see lots
of conifers
which is again the total focus of this
garden
we're about you know 200 maybe meters
into our journey across north america at
this point and we're going to move into
um it's hard to say what's my favorite
of the four gardens but this garden here
is a pretty spectacular garden
so this is our gary oak meadow and
woodland garden
um it's a garden that is neither the
oldest
nor the youngest it's been on site for
about 15 years
and is a representative of a local
meadow ecosystem that occurs here in
vancouver
so this is the distribution of these
gary oak meadows
in the wild they are characterized um
by a plant called the gary oak corcus
gariana it's the only oak native to
british columbia and
the range on this ecosystem you can see
sweeps down through on the
eastern slopes of those coastal
mountains
that we were talking about when we were
talking about the pacific slope garden
which is a lot drier this is in rain
shadow area
and then comes back out to the coast in
northern california
but if you look closely above the
national boundary there is a splattering
of red
in vancouver and
locally these meadows are restricted to
the eastern coast
of vancouver island similar to the rain
shadow that happens throughout the
coastal mountains there's a bit of a
rain shadow
on vancouver island so warm moist air
comes
over the crest hits the island drops
most of its moisture on the west side
and there's a bit of a sunnier break if
you will by vancouver standards i mean
still
it's it's not southern california but by
vancouver standards it's a little drier
and and with that uh supports a very
different
plant community most of our
native plant community is conifer
dominated forests large stature trees
very very damp very very dark and by
contrast
these meadows that creep up into north
america
are are open and sunny and exposed and
with that a whole different
plant community exists one of the
reasons that i would like to mention
the distribution is because there are a
number of plants in this
garden and i'll get to the garden itself
in a second that are
of local conservation concern so when we
have
forest or plant communities that have
this type of range
fairly extensive in the united states
but just come up
into into canada the way that plant
uh risk and threat is assessed is
there's three levels there's a
provincial or state assessment a
national assessment
and then a global assessment so a number
of the plants
that occur in the gary oak meadows by
the very nature of it being very
restricted here in canada
are considered nationally endangered um
a number of these plants are not
necessarily at risk
of going extinct in the wild but
we are at risk of losing them in
our local populations and
plants at these extended range uh sort
of
far extents of these ranges are
particularly valuable for plant
conservation
in that they may possess genetics that
allow them
to be better adapted to
extremes in throughout their um their
range
so when we talk about the conservation
value of the gary oak meadows here we're
talking about
by and large uh population conservation
as opposed to just a tax on conservation
and the gary oak meadows are extremely
at risk uh here in british columbia
i was mentioning that this is a little
bit drier a little bit sunnier
it's coastal it's got beautiful views
and this is exactly where people want to
settle
and it's estimated that um about two and
a half percent
of what was originally intact gary oak
meadows remain
the meadows themselves are totally
gorgeous this is the
gary oak meadow here at ubc
and what you can see is in stark
contrast to the rainforest garden that i
showed
open exposed sunny sites that just
support
really diverse grasses and forbs
the gary oak meadow even though it's
quite limited in its distribution if you
think back to that range map in canada
is is actually hosts more biodiversity
and specifically plant biodiversity than
anywhere else
in our province even though it's got
such a limited range
so a very important garden for
conservation
and our messaging around human impact
uh with plants um and
what people can do to help help the
cause
however this garden didn't always look
quite this lush when i
arrived in july of 2016
the meadow was largely dormant and the
following spring
um i did a bit of an assessment it
my job is to care for and oversee these
accessioned collections
but without knowing what's in them it's
hard to make decisions about how to best
do that
so in the first year i was here we did
an inventory of this meadow
and on the bottom right you see tim chip
char he's one of our horticulturists
here
and i was fortunate to work with tim he
has a number of years
of field botany experience as well so we
went through this meadow
and took herbarium specimens and
identified all the species that were
remaining in here
because over time this meadow had sort
of moved around as is the case with a
lot of these style of plantings
things had moved things had seeded
around things had died out
and the records weren't always kept up
when we finished the inventory and we
finally
you know settled on agreement on some of
the the taxes that we were seeing in
here
i don't know that i slept for about a
week because i was just in shock
this meadow in certain areas had become
completely overrun
by invasive grasses largely
sweet vernal grass and creeping bent
grass although a few others
so well the photo on the left may look
quite pretty
oh look a meadow with some canvas in it
that
sort of burgundy grass that you see is
sweet vernal grass and you can see that
is
almost all that's left in some instances
95 cover and sweet vernal grass is
incredibly allelopathic so it's actively
suppressing the growth and regeneration
of the native plants that were in here
um
and tackling this meadow is a bit of a
challenge because here at ubc we don't
use
um any herbicides pesticides this is a
garden-wide mandate
and so typically in a in a meadow
restoration you
in a in a situation like this you'd go
in and you'd apply
glyphosate a couple of times and
basically start from scratch
however um we've just been marching
ahead with
um basically digging this meadow out
over a series of three years
all is not lost though um there were
sections of our meadow that were still
intact and so this is what this meadow
looks like in the spring it's incredibly
rich with ephemeral plants
again mentioning that it's a dry
summer area and as much as our region is
a temperate rainforest we do experience
a very significant summer drought
and this meadow is totally adapted for
it so in spring you have all these
ephemerals that
come up a lot of geophytes bulbs things
like that but also annual plants they
put on this tremendous show
and then by mid-summer the garden is
going dormant
and we were able to identify through our
inventory
areas in this garden that remained
intact so on the left is actually
the garden at ubc on the right is a gary
oak meadow out on vancouver island i
visited
and you can see that there are still a
lot of similarities
and we did have these pockets that we
could pull from
and so what we've been doing is
propagating those plants
and as we march the meadow renovation
forward reintroducing
uh plants from those original accessions
that remain
again it's a lot of work but totally
worth it because this garden is
locally endangered checks all our boxes
from our mission
in terms of conservation supporting
scientific research research
education to the public we have a
tremendous amount of interpretive
signage in this garden
and as well as display it is absolutely
breathtaking
in the display that happens in this
garden and it's it's working on the
right is an
area that was renovated two years ago
and
uh what we see here is actually more
indicative of what these meadows would
look like these are
the grasses the good guys that should be
here a mix of annual and perennial
forbs and growing in and amongst those
grasses
and now that we've been able to rid
ourselves of those
allelopathic grasses these plants are
actually seeding themselves back into
the garden
so no shortage of hard work but a
complete success story
and and one i'm quite proud of
and as i mentioned the gary oak meadows
are
a threatened ecosystem here and there
are a number of endangered plants that
we have
in this garden these are just a few of
them
some of them are quite showy and
charismatic you know in the center
are a couple of our less charismatic
ones a sedge carrots tumula cola
and camisolemia contorted a little
yellow flower that's
a few millimeters across so not all of
our conservation
plants you would even notice when you
walk through this garden but it's
loaded with them all of these plants
that you see here though
are secure throughout the southern
portion of this range of the gary oak
meadow
however uh one particular plant that i'm
particularly interested in in this
meadow and that we've been successful
with
is called golden paintbrush and so this
is a plant called castella levasecta
castellaia are in the orobank ac family
and it's a family of plants that are
largely parasitic or hemi parasitic
castella levasecta is a hemi-parasitic
plant so it parasitizes other plants
but also produces chlorophyll so it can
self-sustain
but does much better if it has host
plants
castellaia are notoriously difficult to
propagate and then even more so
cultivate in a garden setting they're
one of those things that people always
say best
left in the wild don't even try um
but we've been trying here and we've had
a lot of success uh so castella
lovasecta
been able to propagate a few hundred of
these quite successfully with a few
different hosts you can see it on the
left it's growing with a native fescue
um and we also grow it with a few
crassula seed plants
and we've now planted these out into the
meadow for a second year now and we're
seeing about a 60
65 success rate which by all accounts is
very very good for this plant
so a bit of a success story here and
unlike the plants in the previous slide
this is a plant that is not only at risk
here in bc and canada at a national
level but is globally endangered
extremely limited range on this plant in
the wild
and the same threats that face the gary
oak meadows here
in british columbia are present
throughout the rest of this plant's
range to the south
i've been very fortunate to work with
some local
recovery teams who have supplied us with
high quality
known provenance seeds so we can grow
plants that are
legitimately of conservation value for
this endangered species
and finally we're in the home stretch
we're about to cross the finish line as
we run the 350 meters
we're going to end off in the carolinian
forest garden
um this is a garden that
might be confusing to to many of you you
know is this the flora of the carolinas
specifically what is the carolinian um
the carolinian forest zone is
largely a canadian term it originated
uh from some plant biologists and
silviculturists um back in the 18th and
early 1900s
and it was a term used to describe a
very distinct
forest system that shows up just in
southern ontario
so if you're familiar with the area on
the top left
you see that there's this sweeping line
that says northern limit of the
carolinian zone
and it kind of sweeps from north of
toronto down towards london
and over to grand bend very very limited
distribution of this forest type in
canada and uh also
if you think about the development in
canada and particularly in ontario
this is also the most densely populated
and heavily human impacted
region in our country
so there's a lot of parallels between
this
this forest and the gary oak meadows in
terms of
national plant conservation northern
range
conservation and education around human
impact
in the landscape
the the photo on the left bottom does
show
that that light sort of lime green color
is the eastern deciduous forest
and that's really what you probably
would know the carolinian as
so uh an ecosystem and a forest type
that does
have a much larger range uh and a number
of the plants that we grow here
are very abundant um south of the border
but
quite rare from a national perspective
again a similarity
with this garden and the gary oak meadow
is the biodiversity here is extremely
high from a national level
the you can see just how limited that
range is
but half of canada's tree species grow
in that range and over half of
its vascular plant species so all the
grasses
and forbs and things like that over half
of our national plant biodiversity can
be found
growing in these forests despite their
extremely limited range
and on the right is typically what this
forest looks like in the wild i was
fortunate to grow up
in this forest when dawn mentioned i
spent my youth exploring the forest and
propagating plants from
my local surroundings this was the
forest i was trekking through
so i was very happy when i arrived here
to find that a little piece of home also
met me here on the west coast
and this garden is
also about 12 13 years old so not the
oldest not the youngest
and this is what it looks like right now
as you know
probably the the most well-known aspect
of the eastern deciduous forest is its
fall color
i have to say that we don't get the fall
color here in vancouver that
we get back in the east even though
we're growing the same plants
and i think that's largely um climactic
we don't get those
wild swings between cold cold nights and
warm
days that would very quickly break down
chlorophyll um but we do get some nice
fall color and then again this is the
shot of that garden you can see some
lovely light coming in however there
wasn't always lovely light coming in
when i arrived
in this garden it was
obvious to me that a number of trees
need to be cut down so because we don't
use
herbicides here when this garden was
created it was put on top of
what used to be sort of weedy herbaceous
ornamental beds
and those plants were dug out but a
number of them were very
aggressive and there were a number of
persistent perennial weeds so the
decision was made to plant this garden
extremely densely with
large stature trees in an effort to
shade out
those uh weeds which is part of an
integrated pest management plan when you
don't use herbicides
however these trees were not thinned as
they grew and so
the first few months that i was here i
did a quick assessment and in my first
winter
we actually removed something like 85
trees from this garden and i'm pretty
sure it raised a few eyebrows like did
we hire the wrong guy why is he cutting
down
our garden um but it was a decision that
needed to be made because these trees
are growing extremely fast in our
climate
much faster than they would back east
and we were getting to this crucial
point where
if we let them live any longer they
would become complicated removals based
on their size and proximity to one
another
but the the result is that the remaining
trees
have responded exceptionally well and
some of those trees are extremely
important to us here at ubc
um ubc botanical garden is part of the
plant collections network
and for magnolias and and maples
uh cordell botanic garden is part of
this group for the maples
and and as a result of some of that
thinning a number of our
key accessions have done extremely well
and responded well to
increased light and increased air
circulation
a couple of super charismatic plants
here magnolia macrophylla and magnolia
virginiana
are amongst our magnolia collections and
the photo on the left is not
a trick of the eye these these flowers
are up to a foot across
and and just incredibly showy plants
i know there was one of these outside um
the offices at cornell botanic garden
that unfortunately came down while i was
a student due to
i think structural concerns um
so i hope that the garden is considering
having
another in its collections because
they're wonderful plants
and also through the thinning we managed
to be able to successfully grow plants
in the understory so previously
light was not coming through this forest
after the clearing the
shrub layer in the understory has
responded incredibly well
rhododendrons that previously bloomed
only moderately have now
decided to put on a riot of color in the
spring this is rhododendron vasii
another of
our threatened plants this one's
globally threatened and we have
four accessions represented by 30 some
odd plants
all of known wild provenance
conservation value aside this is just a
spectacularly gorgeous plant
um that blooms in the early spring
before any of the leaves come out you
see these
pink puffballs in the landscape
and then also with with the increased
light we can now grow plants in the
understory that are herbaceous
previously
this garden was too shady and too dense
to really support these plants
and really this is where a lot of the
magic happens in this garden
um the spring ephemerals that occur in
the
woods around campus if you think about
how rich and beautiful that scene is
we are now able to create that here and
so i've been working very hard over the
last few years
to create that with a lot of success
and i just wanted to show you how we
create that so i'm fortunate
that a number of our volunteers and our
friends of the garden
support me financially to do wild plant
collecting and this is very important
for our garden in terms of meeting our
mission
of curating a collection of
known provenance wild collected material
and so this is
probably you know the highlight of my
job there are bugs everywhere i get
soakers i get banged up but it's
incredibly
rewarding to go out on these trips and
collect plants
uh to bring them back for our garden and
it takes me everywhere from
lakeside to forest to dry interior
to alpine mountain tops and this is
really
um a crucial part of my job it seems
like
you know this would be minor but there
aren't a lot of opportunities for
wild collected seed available to me
unless i do collecting
um so a crucial part of what i do and
that's largely how i build my
collections here
at ubc and so that's been a 350
meter walk across north america and some
of the exciting plants
and plant communities and i encourage
you all to
get out into your local forest and
appreciate them
as well as come visit us at ubc if you
can and at this point i'd like to
thank cornell university for the years
that i spent there the friendships and
knowledge that i gained
i'd also like to thank um cows in
particular
for supporting the public garden
leadership
program and to cornell botanic gardens
for also making that possible i wouldn't
be where i am without it and a special
thanks to
all the grad students uh maria is
pictured here she's the one who reached
out to me initially
maria and dawn to invite me here to
speak so thank you it's been a pleasure
we've got a few minutes for some
questions
well i want to thank ben for an
absolutely
fascinating presentation and i so
appreciated ben
that you spoke not only about the
horticultural considerations of the
plants
in your collections but also the
botanical and biogeographic
considerations so absolutely fabulous
and i will now
um welcome any questions that folks may
have for ben
and ben you can also look in the chat
feature
where i believe that there is at least
one question
all right okay i've got the chat window
open now
uh okay so um um wreck beach i'm just
going to address that first it is
actually
right across the road from us yeah so uh
a number of our staff at the end of a
hot day in august will head straight
down to the beach
um is prescribed there's a question is
prescribed uh
controlled fire used as a management
tool um
it is not um it's something that i would
like to do
from a demonstration perspective however
in our gary oak meadow our
our largest issue right now are the the
grasses and the grasses we're dealing
with are also fire adapted
so it would be a tool that we could use
if we got into situations where we were
seeing
um woody plants moving in and that sort
of thing but
right now burning that meadow would
not actively solve too much of
the the issue that we're dealing with
however
um i'm glad you mentioned fire because
the gary oak meadows
as they exist were also extremely
important to the local indigenous
cultures
and they persist not only because of the
soils and the exposure in the climate
but also because
of a history of prescribed burn by the
local indigenous cultures to keep the
the area open because a number of very
important food and medicine plants
grow in that ecosystem so in the wild
fire is actually an incredibly important
part
of of that that ecosystem
in our garden management not so much
it's also
very difficult to set any part of the
campus on fire
and the rules and regulations around
that are are
very very tight
and i invite uh any of the other
participants to
unmute themselves if they do have a
question for ben
let me ask a question um
the various collections that you showed
us
are more what i would refer to
as naturalistic rather than
highly designed how do you
interpret them for the public so that
visitors can appreciate these as
horticultural collections
and not as what you were saying just
parks
yeah it's a very good question and it is
definitely one of our challenges i mean
the whole of ubc botanic garden um
by and large is focused on
plants as they would occur in a natural
way
we do have some uh more formal spaces a
physic garden and a food garden and
a sort of an events lawn with a more
traditional
perennial border and that sort of thing
um
one of the things that we try and do is
we luckily had an interpretive
plan developed three years ago
now that involved a number of
very large well-designed information
boards to help people understand what it
was that they were seeing
so in front of strategic locations or
strategic
plants or plantings talking about the
plants
that they're seeing we also
through our database we use a data
behind all of this
as a custom database called iris bg
which is a software that was developed
specifically for managing
botanic collections and through that
we have launched a garden explorer so
people can go
on this app and look for
particular plants or based on the area
that they're standing in
know what plants are around them
and we've also designed through that a
number of specific
tours that our guests can take
that we'll take them around to specific
plants
um and yeah we try and make sure that
all of our collections are accurately
labeled but particularly those that are
along those
predetermined earth
any final questions for ben ah here we
go from
raleigh ah yes okay
so uh
he's mentioning that we have a canopy
walk here
in the garden it's actually not in my
rainforest garden it's in the asian
garden
and our asian garden um is planted
amongst an
intact uh coastal rainforest and you can
go up through the canopy
and one of the things that we do get
here even though i was saying that we
don't get
as lush and moss sort of diversity
hanging from
branches and things like that in our
asian garden in particular because it's
has an irrigation system and and higher
humidity
we do get epiphytes growing so um
various bryophytes in the canopy and
a few fern species by and large
um the canopy itself
isn't sort of actively managed in that
garden space beyond the way that it
impacts the asian plant collections
below
so decisions are made about removals and
thinning and planting
of the overstory but it's largely
in a way or decisions made about the
impact that would have
on the asian plants that grow beneath
and to the best of my knowledge there
haven't been any active studies
up in that canopy
we do engage with researchers from the
university
um but largely
the the research that happens here is
driven by the interests of
of the labs on campus so we provide what
we can based on
what they need as opposed to actively
sort of directing that research so
if if people on campus aren't interested
in studying it we actually don't have
the capacity in our staff
to study it our involvement in research
is to supply material to researchers
as opposed to in-house research
unfortunately we have run out of time
so i want to again thank ben
for an intriguing and information
filled presentation thank you so much
ben
we are sorry that you can't be with us
in person but look forward to seeing you
again sometime in the future
i look forward to visiting thanks don
okay
bye bye now bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu